y cuando se apagó el fuego solo quedarán
cenizas las autoridades españolas dieron
por terminada la erupción del volcán de
Cumbre Vieja en la isla de La Palma
ubicada en las Canarias lo hicieron
después de 10 días sin actividad sísmica
lo que quiero hoy decir se dice con muy
pocas palabras con cuatro palabras
la ilusión a terminado había pensado que
la palabra adecuada es la palabra Alirio
y 100 días desde el inicio de su
actividad el volcán se apagó dejando a
su paso más de 7000 evacuados
destruyendo alrededor de 1700 edificios
y llegando a 1218 hectáreas el Gobierno
se ha comprometido a invertir
453000000 de dólares para la
reconstrucción
las afectaciones son consecuencia de los
150 millones de metros cúbicos de magma
expulsados por el cono de Cumbre Vieja
los expertos dicen que el proceso
volcánico todavía seguirá mucho tiempo y
los habitantes de la isla deberán
acostumbrarse a los terremotos alguno os
han establecido una relación especial
con la erupción
con este apagón de Cumbre Vieja en
plenas Navidades se cierra uno de los
capítulos más destructivos y
espectaculares de 2021